Hollywood we got Taylor Swift in there
how was it working with her my God I got
to hear her singing right next to me
what an Angelic voice what a pleasure
that was yeah Taylor
[Music]
and this
now Christian and Taylor are singing
together with John David Washington in
their new movie Amsterdam Margot Robbie
and Rami Malek co-star we've got a
musical Credit in this thing along with
John David and Taylor yeah how unlikely
is that you know uh it's so cool that my
family has to put up with her and me
sing around the house I certainly get no
compliments uh there but uh holy crap
yeah they couldn't get me off the stage
I enjoyed it so much that is addictive
Christian could sing We found that out
Taylor was all right Christians like
that friend that is always like let's go
do karaoke and you're like okay well and
they really push for it and then you get
to karaoke and they have an amazing
voice and you're like that's why you
push the karaoke yeah he's gonna boys
appreciate it but you know it's reserved
for karaoke and yeah
ourselves a situation where we're
accused of killing someone which is not
true set in the 30s this dramedy about a
real-life conspiracy to overthrow the
government features an ensemble cast
that includes Chris Rock Zoe Saldana
Anya Taylor joy and Michael Shannon
Robert De Niro told us shooting got a
little hectic there's a lot of things
that happen in the moment lines being
thrown which sometimes are the best way
they can be read Mike Myers rounds out
the cast of the movie that's in theaters
today he's celebrating the 20 th
anniversary of Austin Powers in gold
member with Beyonce it's me foxy she was
always recording an album I would say
what are you listening to and she said
How's something I'm working on then she
said to me what are you listening to
right now I said I just got back into
Led Zeppelin
and she goes I don't know this Led
Zeppelin and she's super young and she
goes I will listen to Led Zeppelin she
said next day I come in and I go he's
still working on an album she goes it's
Led Zeppelin it's so good
[Music]